une première pour la nouvelle équipe de
l'office de tourisme de reims justement
à travers une campagne d'affichage qui
utilisent la grenouille symbole du
français la municipalité veut inciter
les anglais qui débarque à calais à
faire un petit souk ahras
et
en général pour un français l'humour
anglais c'est comme la traversée de la
manche à la longue on finit par s'y
habituer
partant de là la ville de reims a
imaginé une campagne de promotion
touristique par affiche entre douvres et
calais utilisant la grenouille qui
symbolise le français aux yeux des
grands bretons en y associant sa soeur
jumelle canterbury race a donc remplacé
le coq gaulois par la grenouille
anglaise les anglais moore et nous nous
sommes dit on va parler nous sommes les
plus beaux les plus grands les plus
forts ça n'est pas très personne tout le
monde le dit et je me dis il faut
trouver un accroche un accroche-coeurs
pour que les anglais se dit chan
où s'arrêtera bien harrah's avec
beaucoup de gens en angleterre en ce
sens nous et cette image qu'ils ont une
bonne dose aussi j'allais conneries sur
la vitre av voiture comme ça en me
baladant à canterbury
les gens pourront joueurs reims est une
belle ville du like it fois que vous
aimez manger grenouille
ah oui j'adore mais si difficile d'en
trouver en angleterre mais si l'humour
n'a pas de frontière n'est pourtant pas
que vos nouilles qui veut
chaque année plus de 15 millions
d'anglais traversent la manche
un million seulement passe par reims en
lançant cette campagne dont le budget ne
dépasse pas les 150 mille francs
l'office de tourisme rémois compte bien
associer l'image de la grenouille à
celle du champagne en profitant de la
récente mise en service de l'autoroute
a26 qui mérens à 12h30 de calais
pourtant avec deux affiches à calais 2 à
boulogne et une à douvres on ne peut pas
dire que les grenouilles passe à
l'offensive d'autant que les anglais ne
semble pas les digérer mais je pense que
c'est une plaisanterie très mauvaise
c'est horrible c'est magnifique c'est
très désolé que vous pensez que les
français ne sont pas des grenouilles
pourquoi
que dit la france est désormais à
bichkek
ne tournez pas sa première étape de
cette campagne de promotion la
grenouille comme celle de la fable devra
faire attention par la suite à ne pas
avoir les yeux plus gros que le ventre